what's the most unprepared you've ever
been as a director and what did that
teach you I feel you know what I
honestly feel unprepared a lot and that
drives me to to be more prepared it is
the worst feeling in the world to show
up it doesn't even have to be on set it
could be at a client meeting or a
production meeting where you realize you
haven't done your due diligence I
remember this was a client job a
commercial project where I ended up
showing up late to the meeting when
everyone was on time but me and because
I didn't plan right and I didn't have
the concept fully thought through and I
was saying things in the meeting about
the project that they wanted to do you
know like we want to advertise this XYZ
product and I had not researched it it's
embarrassing you're scrambling you're
hoping to god they don't realize that
you're unprepared if it's the worst
worst feeling in the world
what did it teach me it taught me that I
know that there is sometimes a
resistance to preparation I don't know
where this resistance comes from but
sometimes there is I mean sometimes it
feels like work it's not the sexy part
research I am NOT even a natural
researcher let's say it's let's say it's
a movie about a court case criminal
trial let's say you have a courtroom
drama well I don't know that much about
the legal system but it would behoove me
to research it if I'm doing a movie on
it because the more I know about how
courts work and how lawyers do their
jobs and all that kind of thing the
better off I'm going to be on my feet
but that's not sexy that's not fun
that's not working with an actor working
out a character it's
it feels hard honestly doing commercial
corporate work has really helped prepare
me for that kind of thing because it
makes me have to dig into things I
didn't think I'd ever want to dig into
you know and being on time there's not
so frustrating for everybody else when
they are showing up before the director
like there they're there because of what
you know that says that they're more
into this than you are you don't want to
be in that position you don't want your
crew going dude it's 20 people were
supposed to meet 20 minutes that's
that's not good
that's not a way to inspire trust with
your team or preparedness yeah that's
all I've learned that over and over in
the heart and I run late I often am late
to things and that's a real challenge to
me to do that
so definitely punctuality is important I
liked in fact on set I like to try to be
there before everybody else gets there
that feels that and the feeling you get
on the flip side of to be there prepared
before everyone else gets there once you
feel that it's hard to go back it takes
a lot of work but to know your scene
backwards so that if there's a problem
and you can go no no the guy would never
have a red curtain on his window because
he that color reminds him of you just
know that world so well you could just
contstantly answer all those questions
you're not sitting there going on yeah
you don't be there is such a great
feeling after you've done the work and
you've worked so hard to get there and
everybody knows it haha that's so great
it's so great I really wanted to go back
to the sex analogy right but I often
noticed that I'm unprepared when I'm
really busy so it's a lot of good things
that are happy and you never anticipate
that that's gonna be a problem you just
think I want to have a B and C happen
and it's gonna be great but then what
happens is
you're not prepared for one of them a
few of them and then it can sabotage
things anyway absolutely this is the
thing they don't teach you in film
school is is what light what life can do
to you when you're trying to make it and
oftentimes the better the opportunity
the bigger it is the more things like I
don't have time to prepare for the job
will happen or you know even just
getting a film off the ground like well
oftentimes we'll get in these jobs
because everybody has to make a living
one of working 15 hours a day and we're
too tired to prepare at the end or too
tired to write that screenplay and you
end up not you don't teach you about
that in film school we all think and
when we're 21 that we're just gonna have
all this time to prepare and come to set
no one's gonna be on the same team
that's that that's where the true test
of who you are comes into play like it
doesn't matter if you haven't had time
you better you better be prepared if you
don't have the time leading up and you
should probably have started earlier
like or something but it's so important
like and I think it does test your
mettle for sure so when you are early
what are the first let's say five things
you do as a director let's suppose
you've you're in command you're there so
early and you've coffee'd up or I don't
know maybe not just whatever just you
feel good and you're there early what no
what man that's a great question so I
there are many times I've been on set
and there's no one there yet and there
is such a piece that hat that can
because you know there's like there's
energy in the room that you feel that
it's coming because you know you're
about to create something in the room is
waiting it's just in waiting and
probably the first thing I do is just to
really envelop at that like breathe into
it I mean into that like you know just
to take them I want to drop into it I
would say the second thing is and I'm
I'll do this throughout the shoot as
well too
wake up and realize man I got some
lights and all these people and a lot of
these people are my close friends like
to really like be present that's so hard
to do sometimes on a film set but if
you're there early and you have a chance
to like really check in and be present
and go through it all like really
setting your mind state mental state
before you start that's that's huge
beyond that I like to you know check
through the script make double double
check Donnell the i's and cross the t's
yeah they say that right yeah before I
go you know make sure I know that intent
to the scene I'm about to shoot that day
you know it does this make sense this is
where we're going sometimes I will even
pre-planned what I'm going to tell an
actor because sometimes it could be hard
to know what to say but that's a big one
for me to be able to understand okay
this is gonna be a hard emotion to hit
how am I gonna how am I gonna get them
to that place I'm gonna try telling them
this story or I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
tell in this kind of direction I'll do
that a lot as well yeah so I don't know
if that was five points but that's a few
things that I definitely try to do it
you know what else I do for me
personally as a director a lot of times
I am so sensitive to since there's the
opposite downs to being like an
emotional person I'm a very emotive
person that works really well for me
when I'm working with actors because I
can sense emotion and I'm looking to try
to pull it out of you and I'm I'm
looking to see if you're shutting down
or opening up or feeling defensive or
you're feeling scared like I have to be
you have to turn those sensors on well
that can also work against me when I see
that the crew is tired and I see that
they don't want to be there or they're
distracted so I as my one of my
struggles is that I will sometimes not
get for everything I
or keep shooting until I get what I want
because I'm afraid of abusing the crew
I'm so terrified of like like you know
what I don't want the reputation of the
guy that works everyone 17 hours in like
not thankful you know like let's I
wanted to be proud you know what I mean
so I will sometimes have to talk myself
into it cuz this is what will happened
to me we'll be shooting in someone will
go did you get it I'm like well not
quite but I'm worried because I don't
want you guys to have to keep working
and usually the crew will go were you
crazy were here let's just do it like if
that's that's what usually happens it's
funny that they're trying to talk me
into keeping going it's just hilarious
but I will oftentimes very importantly
look at my struggles and go it's ok to
ask for another if you need it like you
know to essentially talking myself into
it and kind of hyping myself up for that
kind of day sure when your sensitivity
over there's the one with the arms
crossed that's just you could just feel
their muttering under their breath you
know and you don't know what you've done
but yeah it's totally mad at you and
they're like this is amazing sexy right
I mean and and so being a sensitive
person yeah that's the boy I read that
energy so well and you know the funny
thing is I've learned is what my wife
has taught me this is that often times
when that happens it has nothing to do
with you
because they just got the call that
their kids got in trouble at school or
whatever like it's half the time has
nothing to do with you at all or that's
just how they stand
[Laughter]
you